in today's morning rounds the physical
and emotional challenges of a special
pregnancy a transgender man in Oregon
gave birth to a baby boy he shared his
pregnancy on social media in the hopes
of changing the stigma surrounding it an
estimated 1.4 million adults in the u.s.
identify as transgender but the
government has no documented numbers on
transgender men who have given birth
Mireya Villarreal spoke to the family
about their journey we've got strawberry
tomato baby Leo's life story starts in a
familiar place feeding burping and
soothing the two week old already looks
like a synchronized routine for his
parents
Tristan Reese and Biff chat lo daddy's
getting at they all have a match the
couple's family started when they took
in and later adopted chap Lowe's
one-year-old niece and three-year-old
nephew that's the face of pure love
Leo's birth offers another twist to the
plot how did this work I mean you had
transitioned you were a male Reese was
born a female but grew up identifying as
a male at 20 years old he started taking
testosterone transitioning through
hormone therapy alone he opted not to
have surgery once the couple decided
they wanted to have a baby the next step
was the easy one
it's actually not that different than if
a woman is on hormonal birth control
okay and their cycle stops so I stopped
taking my hormones and eventually my
cycle came back about five months later
we got the positive pregnancy test when
you're pregnant and and you have this
belly
did you ever kind of stop and look at
yourself in the mirror and kind of go
whoa you know or for that matter did you
get those looks on the sidewalks did
people ask about it were they curious
men's bodies are not scrutinized in the
ways that women's bodies are so nobody
really noticed that I was pregnant it
just kind of look like I had a beer
belly for a good chunk of the time
people thought you were fat yeah I'm
okay being trans I think it's kind of
awesome actually and I've never wanted
my body to be different recent chat lows
shared updates throughout the pregnancy
on social media
using the platform to address
misconceptions about transgender people
we did take steps in those end months
like Tristan started working from home
completely we just didn't go out as much
to be cautious you do have to admit that
the what you have here is unconventional
so for those people who say this isn't a
family how do you respond to them we're
not here for people who are at that
place if you are so blind to love and to
respect and to the possibility that the
world has to offer you that you don't
think that what is in this house is a
family there's no way I'm gonna reach
you Rison Chapel oh no their story isn't
every once but it's someone's it's the
teenagers that think they might be trans
or the gay men out there that feel
ashamed of themselves
it's those sorts of people that we feel
like we would like to reach there are so
many different configurations of
families all of which are valid and full
of love and respects and integrity and
spit-up
for CBS this morning media vol Portland
Oregon
Reese is not the first transgender man
to give birth and in sharing his family
story he told Maria he's not even the
first in his circle of friends it's an
amazing story I love that line about
because he was walking around as a man
no one even noticed he was pregnant they
just thought he had a fear that that's
right and sharing it on social media so
that everybody can understand and learn
a little bit more about is great